your ms the descendant of an ancient
conqueror but was asked but the very
people once subjugated to lead them
serving is both a weighty blade and a
stone hard shield to understand your
let's look into the history of the
profaned capital the realm which he
ruled over by the time of Dark Souls 3
it's clear that the Capitals glory days
are behind it it's a shadow of its
former self being comprised mainly of
ruins and crumbling rock to be more
precise the fall of the profaned capital
happened even before pontiff sullivan
came to power the profaned great sword
pontiff's right hand weapon tells long
ago when sullivan was yet a young
sorcerer
he discovered the profaned capital and
an unfading flame below a distant tundra
of era though Sullivan is known to have
been in power after Aldridge sainted the
deed became a lord of cinder via
Sullivan was the one who helped Aldrich
attain his second epithet the power of
gods if you want to know more about
Aldridge and his surroundings check out
my other lore video on just that topic
in addition to this the jailers that we
find in Aerith Hill dungeon were among
the few survivors inhabiting the
profaned capital later serving under
pontiff Sullivan from this evidence it's
now confirmed that the high time of your
and the profaned capital occurred much
much earlier than when the events of
Dark Souls 3 take place however the last
text I read mentioned that the arathor
jailers were among the few survivors
survivors of what you may ask that what
is the cause of the profaned capital's
downfall the text of the aristocrats
masque implies an across-the-board
destructive phenomenon that decimated
the capital only leaving a select few
alive the event is given description by
the pyromancy profane flame which states
the profaned capital was consumed by
fire after your the giant became a lord
of cinder the fire born in the sky is
said to have incinerated naught but
human flesh
so the linking of the fire biome caused
a catastrophe of fire large enough to
practically wipe out his entire Dominion
and more or less put it in the
dilapidated state we observe in the game
we'll go into greater detail about the
destructive flame a bit later
but for now let's look at what the
capital was like before the
great fire from items Armour and NPCs we
can piece together some of the key
elements of yours ruling prior to its
demise a hostile Embassy near the toxic
lake area appearing to be an old court
sorcerer drops big hat Logan's calm when
killed the tone reads the court
sorcerers used this scroll to claim
airship to Logan's legacy so magic had
an important place in the capital as
claiming legacy to Logan one of the
greatest sorcerers of all time requires
some serious merit to be taken seriously
and it appears that the capital could
put its money where its mouth was as it
housed one of the two leading schools of
sorcerers that claimed airship to the
great sage big hat Logan Norm's realm
had an entire school dedicated to
sorcery and even acquired the scroll of
big hat Logan we can see that the
profaned capital was definitely a hub
for magic additionally the grand
architecture of buildings an enormous
store of gold and silver communicate the
prosperity and affluence that the
capital once held this paired with the
fact that citizens had enough resources
in time to devote heavy study to magic
affirms that you're ruled over a great
Kingdom I was experiencing a sort of
golden age before it's expiration now
well the magic was indeed an indicator
of success these core sorcerers seem to
be a little more than what meets the eye
their hoods and robes contain some gold
stitching that hints at the sorcerers
also beam Oracle's these Oracle's could
be related to the Oracle referenced by
the axe
Eleonora which drops from one of the
monstrosity of sin near the toxic lake
the axe reads the profaned flame was
triggered by the curse of these women
relatives of a certain Oracle but
despite their culpability
they went on living without any cares
from this parallels can start to be
drawn between the profaned capital and
Allium voice from Dark Souls 2 both
include a frozen Overland Elam voice for
two and Aerith Hill for three with a
powerful and harsh flame underneath the
flame of chaos and the profane to flame
respectively what's more is that the
flames of chaos were kept at bay by all
sama the silent Oracle emphasis on
Oracle all of this paired with the
disjointedness of space-time in Dark
Souls 3 could very well mean to these
two places are one in the
st. providing a lot more backstory for
your arms SETI yet let's not get too
carried away with speculation
so we've acquired a bit of knowledge on
what the profane capital was like before
its fall now we can begin to really
discuss the story of yore and expand
upon some topics I've only touched on so
far the orbs most obvious feature is his
massive size he's a giant there is some
speculation on who he is the descendant
of however the first instinct would be
to make the connection between him and
the Giants from Dark Souls 2 the largest
roadblock to this theory is that you're
actually has a humanoid face rather than
a hole like the ds2 giants other
theories include yarn being descended
from wall near as wall near along with
being huge in size is for certain a
conqueror and Yoram soul mentioned
someone like this there's no hard
evidence either way though so I will
continue on the assumption that yours
ancestors do not significantly influence
his actions or motivation he's acting of
his own volition
I might discuss more of these ideas and
theories in an extras video like the one
I did for Aldrich Norm's ancestor
conquered the people that he ended up
living with and eventually being asked
to leave it is readily apparent where
the people of the capital would ask you
your to help / leave him he was an
amazing protector with his great shield
Doran became a one-man Vanguard for the
profaned capital he served as the first
line of defense for his subject and act
fairly unheard of for Lords anywhere
Kings generally have their people
protect the royalty and the royalties
wealth but not your he had the power and
will to protect so he did yet through
all his might and strength dorm could
not keep safe the one he wished to
protect above all there's almost no
information on who this one was but when
they were lost norm forsook his shield
he threw away his defensive guard and
aggressively launched himself into his
enemies your Mantid a left-hand notch
onto his great machete so he could smash
his foes with a reckless abandon a style
that would eventually become part of his
legacy perhaps this was the first step
for your in his descent to madness or
whatever state we find him in at the
capital and fight the loss of one so
dear can forever change someone and it
definitely changed yarn now your may
have lost the one he wished to protect
he was still able to protect the
residents of the profaned capital you
could find some solace in that right
well it seems that the people who wished
your arm to be their leader still
harbored disdain frame in their hearts
maybe it was from his ancestors conquest
maybe it was just due to the fact that
he was different
regardless norm did not receive the love
or respect that he was due though
knowing this norm still did his best
Perce people the sinners of the Lord
retrieved from your read lonely or
became a lord of cinder to put the
profaned flame to rest knowing full well
that those who spoke of him as Lord were
quite insincere even though your knew
his subjects were disingenuous he set
himself to link the flame to help them
and put to rest the profane flame I'm
probably gonna make a separate video
dedicated to the profane flame and other
capital Lord as it's too extensive to
cover in this one and still focus on
your but before your did this the people
expressed a fear concerning his linking
they doubted the yarn the one who kept
them safe and led them would always have
their best interests in heart
so to appease their fears joram gave a
storm ruler which had the power to bring
Giants to their knees to the humans that
doubted him and left the other to a dear
friend before facing his fate as a Lord
of cinder norm damned link aflame and
became the Lord of cinder and tragedy
befell him once more after urine became
a Lord of cinder profaned capital was
consumed by a fire born from the sky
which incinerated not the human flesh
his subjects his people whom he had
defended so valiantly and for so long
burned as a result of his linking the
flame the fire of the sky destroyed
yours Kingdom even hardly anyone alive
in your him had to live with those
results after losing the one he wished
to protect dorm really only had the
people he led even among them he was
lonely but he still had something now
that something was gone
it really isn't much of a wonder why we
find you're hostile to us well he
doesn't want to take part in linking of
the flame once more in the past it only
begot him pain and suffering so he now
rejects the flame and has abandoned his
duty as a lord of cinder
I have to say I don't really blame him
however there is still one point of
redemption in your story one shining
beacon that stands out among the tragedy
and ill fortune and that sacred but dear
friend that you're entrusted with the
second storm ruler was sigrid of
catarina
if you progress there sigmoids questline
he will mention a couple of times how
you must keep a grave promise if you've
gone through his entire quest line
sacred will appear at the boss fight
with your saying
friend
I see felt of the Knights of Catarina
have come to uphold my promise
that the sunshine upon this road of
senior the other storm ruler can be
found near your own the citizens which
he gave it to having long since died but
sigrid still had his cigarettes promise
with your must have been to use the
storm ruler to take your down if need be
you're almost aware that he might not
always upholds his same values so he had
his old friend make a severe oath to
uphold them for him it's unsure how your
mistake veered were old friends so here
it is supposedly from Catarina and yours
age of rule has long since passed so
logistically I don't really see how they
could have known each other perhaps
Sigrid has been an undead for an absurd
amount of time without Halloween
maintain his sanity by focusing on his
promise there are a lot of theories but
in the end they're not really too
important Sigurd upheld his promise to
yarn that's what matters yawm lived
through a tragically hard and wretched
life he had but one friend that was able
to stay with him until the end and we
were able to help that friend keep his
promise and give the reclusive lord a
release from this twisted world maybe
now he can be with the one he wished to
protect but could not in any case I
think Siebert said it best may the Sun
Shine upon this Florida cinder yo what
is up everybody my other Ouija here and
I appreciate you watching the video if
you watch the video this far I'm
assuming you liked it and that's great
if you want more lore stuff or more Dark
Souls 3 stuff check around my channel so
that you have other videos of that I'll
be continuing to both other videos of
that if you want really up-to-date stuff
about me posting the videos follow me on
Twitter because I do make updates on
there about the Lord videos and about my
videos in general I've been trying to be
less monotone less bland in these Laura
videos since people have been really
liking these Laura videos but they've
been telling me that a little - monotone
little too bland little too dry so let
me know in the comments if you think
I've improved them that if you think
it's still need to improve on that let
me know also just what your feelings
were about the video in terms of lore
and the production I'm always trying to
get better production wise so if I had
music
I should never should have put music
somewhere or anything like that
gameplay shots all that stuff let me
know in the comments below and yeah
thanks for watching I'm gonna probably
leave right now so yeah peace out